[Musique]
on allait très mal à démarrer et de
nouvelles couleurs d'un petit pays comme
saint cyr de val d'orge à peine 400
habitants qu'est ce qui se passe yayi à
l'église et il ya le bistrot comme
animation en a pour tout le monde et
c'est la seule de sa commune à la salle
paroissiale
mais il commet des séances communes
propose fois il nous faudra aller dont
la baisse une fois par semaine au et le
bistrot c'est tous les jours pour
qu'elle abaisse aussi les jouets et les
avantages de porc aux siens à l'église
ou au bistrot
j'ai pas porté
deux des cas mais c'est fini ont fui au
bistrot on ira jusqu'à leur dernière
après deux heures et environs se
retrouve au café là je me suis jaloux on
en remet sans discuter jouer au camp des
non on peut pas jouer car on essaie
jusqu'à kader attou après munich
non parce que c'est déjà assez s'agit
quoi l'argent pour les consommations
ceci représente une hausse de dépenses à
la fin du mois cet espace de sport du
tout non il n'y a pas d' équipe de
[ __ ] dedans
j'aimerais bien je manque pousser mes
devoirs et stable
qu'est ce qu'on y trouve au bistrot à
l'alcool j'en prenais beaucoup voyagé
ensemble mais vaillants noah c'est
beaucoup quand même un petit peu ça
n'est pas un profil peu plus chez
village oui ça fait quand même tourné en
1 dimanche
les villas juillet de la distraction et
- la nasa les 800 de lanoraie des
distractions dernier dans les bistrots
dans une équipe de foot de choses votons
pour aller jouer si un jeune attend d'en
savoir un peu trop où j'ai dit non c'est
assez pour nager dans le cadre a donné
peu avant un side assist maria carmen
que les pommes bistrot de village des
gens font quoi kaka ne pas voir que pas
vous dire parce que je connais pas les
pays où il ya quand même le café est ce
que j'ai l'impression que si le café
était fermé le village des entrées jouer
quelques feuillets banques
internationales est plus du tout la même
image jour de même qu'un type la semaine
les chasseurs avec les dames après la
messe les jeunes qui suit d'entre eux
c'est important
c'est un petit peu démuni pays passe
portion est ce que les gens tendent ce
bois ruines ici pour se retrouver entre
revoir et on peut se retrouver
toujours très peu de damous seul dans
les cafés les tanneurs tout seul on a
déjà un petit personnage du dimanche
[Musique]
[Rires]
les personnes âgées
[Musique]